[Música]
los 16 empleados de la secretaría de
seguridad del estado mexicano de Chiapas
secuestrados a comienzos de esta semana
fueron liberados este viernes tras
permanecer tres días en cautiverio y ya
se reunieron con sus familiares más de
1000 miembros de la fuerza de seguridad
participaron en su búsqueda la Corte
Suprema de Estados Unidos bloqueó el
plan del gobierno que buscaba con donar
430 mil millones de dólares en pagos
atrasados de préstamos académicos el
pronunciamiento se da un día después de
que el mismo órgano judicial cancelará
el acceso de las minorías a las
universidades
el expresidente de Brasil Jair bolsonaro
no podrá ejercer cargos públicos durante
8 años el ultraderechistat fue hallado
culpable del delito de abuso de poder
por el tribunal federal electoral la
decisión le impide presentarse a las
elecciones presidenciales de 2026
Hola Bienvenidos a esta emisión
informativa de Franz 24 en español
dedicada a las principales noticias del
continente americano Gracias por
acompañarnos comenzamos en México los 16
empleados de la secretaría de seguridad
del estado de Chiapas secuestrados a
comienzos de esta semana fueron
liberados este viernes y tras tres días
de cautiverio se reunieron con sus
familiares quienes habían estado
organizando un plantón en la secretaría
de seguridad de Chiapas exigiendo la
liberación de sus seres queridos más de
1000 miembros de las fuerzas de
seguridad estatales y federales
participaron en la búsqueda de los
empleados administrativos
y la Corte Suprema de Estados Unidos
bloqueó el plan del gobierno de Joe
biden que buscaba perdonar 430 mil
millones de dólares en pagos atrasados
de préstamos académicos se trataba de
una promesa de campaña del presidente
quien lamentó la decisión este
pronunciamiento se da un día después de
que el mismo órgano judicial cancelará
el acceso de las minorías a las
universidades
Esta es otra bofetada a Joe biden por
parte de la mayoría conservadora en la
Corte Suprema de Justicia 6 de 9 jueces
declararon inválida una de las promesas
de campaña del presidente cuando fue
elegido en 2020 la condonación parcial
de la deuda estudiantil el gobierno
perdonaría aproximadamente 430 mil
millones de dólares en préstamos
federales borrando por completo la deuda
de 20 millones de prestatarios la
pregunta aquí no es hay que hacer algo
sino quién tiene la autoridad para
hacerlo y uno de los mayores poderes del
Congreso es el control de la cartera
para los magistrados designados por
George www Bush y Donald Trump la
cancelación de la deuda no respetaría la
separación de poderes y fue una de las
medidas sociales emblemáticas planteadas
por biden en agosto pasado biden
confirmó la eliminación de 10 mil
dólares para prestatarios que ganaran
menos de 125.000 al año y hasta 20 mil
dólares para estudiantes becados el
presidente estadounidense expresó
inmediatamente su decepción y propuso
nuevas vías para lidiar la deuda
estudiantil
sé que millones de estadounidenses están
decepcionados desalentados y enojados
por esta decisión sobre la deuda
estudiantil y tengo que decir que yo
también anteriormente establecimos un
límite los estudiantes prestatarios sólo
podían pagar más del 10% de sus ingresos
para pagar la deuda mi administración
reducirá eso al 5%
la deuda estudiantil preocupa a 43
millones de estadounidenses y a menudo
asciende a decenas o incluso cientos de
miles de dólares para cada uno de ellos
tras el anuncio de la Corte Suprema los
sindicatos de estudiantes protestaron
frente al edificio un día antes el
máximo tribunal estadounidense tomó otra
decisión Ultra conservadora la
cancelación de la discriminación
positiva en las universidades que
garantizaba el acceso de las minorías a
la educación superior seguimos en
Estados Unidos donde la población el eje
vitiq más sufrió un revés en sus
derechos si es que la Corte Suprema
dictaminó este viernes que el derecho
constitucional a la libertad de
expresión permite que ciertas empresas
se nieguen a brindar servicios para
bodas entre personas del mismo sexo la
corte de mayoría conservadora falló a
favor de la diseñadora web Smith que
citó sus creencias cristianas para
negarse a realizar trabajos para
matrimonios igualitarios según el fallo
la ley de Colorado que prohíbe la
discriminación basada en la orientación
sexual obligaría a Smith a crear un
discurso en el que ella no cree y eso
sería una violación de la constitución
más noticias llegan desde Estados Unidos
a partir de este primero de julio entra
en vigor en Florida la nueva ley
impulsada por el gobernador republicano
ron de santis contra la inmigración
irregular la medida genera polémica y
temor por lo que cientos de inmigrantes
se congregaron este viernes para
manifestar su repudio y reclamar una
reforma migratoria integral ampliamos
desde Miami con nuestro corresponsal
Anthony bershi hay temor porque esta ley
sb17-18
obliga a las empresas de más de 25
empleados a utilizar el sistema y verify
para verificar el estatus migratorio de
todos los empleados también se destinan
más de 12 millones de dólares para
trasladar a inmigrantes indocumentados a
otros estados del país además obliga a
los hospitales a reportar a reportar
trimestralmente a los pacientes
indocumentados que atienden y se
invalidan todas las tarjetas de
identificación de otros estados por
ejemplo Nueva York sí que otorga
licencias de y también
tarjetas de identificación a
indocumentados Pues bien a partir de
ahora solo será válida la tarjeta de
Florida Pero el punto que ha causado más
indignación es el que tiene que ver con
el traslado de inmigrantes se contemplan
penas de hasta 15 años de prisión para
aquellos que trasladen a indocumentados
desde otros estados a Florida en los
expertos legales dicen que esta ley da
total discreción para que las
autoridades puedan pedir los papeles los
documentos migratorios a cualquiera en
la calle pero es que incluso los
legisladores republicanos que han
aprobado esta ley aquí en Florida
reconocen que es una ley completamente
con intención política y es para causar
miedo para evitar que los inmigrantes
indocumentados no lleguen a Florida
y noticia de América Latina vamos a
Brasil el Tribunal Superior electoral
condenó al expresidente Jair bolsonaro
por abuso de poder con cinco votos a
favor y dos en contra postulano quedó
inhabilitado para ejercer cargos
públicos durante 8 años una decisión que
le impide presentarse a las elecciones
presidenciales del año 2026 el informe
es de Gabriel
es una sentencia histórica el
expresidente Israel bolsonaro está
oficialmente inhabilitado por 8 años los
siete jueces del tribunal superior
electoral se pronunciaron este viernes
sobre su caso y cinco de ellos lo
reconocieron culpable de abuso de poder
el ponente votó a favor de descartar las
cuestiones preliminares y sobre el fondo
conceder parcialmente la solicitud de
condena del primer acusado Jair Mesías
bolsonaro por la práctica de abuso de
poder político y uso indebido de los
medios de comunicación en las elecciones
de 2022 declarándolo inelegible por 8
años edad
el expresidente fue condenado por haber
deslegitimado el sistema electoral
especialmente durante una reunión con
Embajadores en el Palacio presidencial
en la cual atacó al sistema devoto
electrónico a sólo tres meses de las
elecciones de 2022 también fue
reconocido culpable de uso debido de los
medios de comunicación ya que transmitió
dicho evento en la televisión pública el
expresidente denunció su condena y
anunció que apelará la decisión
Hoy es un día emblemático para mí como
el 6 de septiembre de 2018 cuando me
apuñalaron Hoy recibí una puñalada por
la espalda con esta decisión no es a
Yair Mesías bolsonaro a quien le dieron
esta puñalada sino a la democracia
bolso no podrá presentarse en las
próximas elecciones presidenciales
previstas para 2026 sin embargo el ex
jefe de estado de extrema derecha ya
avisó que podría apoyar a la eventual
candidatura de su esposa Michelle
bolsonaro para las presidenciales
enfrenta a otra decena de
investigaciones judiciales que podrían
ponerlo tras las rejas
eh polémica en Venezuela la contraloría
general confirmado este viernes que la
opositora María Corina Machado inscrita
para participar en las primarias de
octubre previas a las elecciones
presidenciales de 2024 se encuentra
inhabilitada para competir por un cargo
de elección popular por un total de 15
años manchado quien lidera las encuestas
para las primarias calificó como inútil
su inhabilitación ya que según sus
propias palabras quien habilita es el
pueblo de Venezuela
una amenaza más
un obstáculo más
una pasta más una patrulla más se trata
de una inútil
inhabilitación que pretenden
es todo por el momento sigan
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y en France 24.com
[Música]